oh hey jib arm flying in from the sky
it's chris waters here on stage and next
to me is casey holt and i haven't
actually asked him but i'm pretty
positive that we are not actually
related despite what you may think casey
welcome to the stage what's up brother
hi brother it's good to see you yeah
you're here from mechanical butterfly
studios showing off jump tanks that's
correct and you know watching you play
this game here you got it set up the
first thing that strikes me is that does
not look like a tank that I would
normally associate that's something I'd
normally associate with the word tank
exactly yeah it's inspired by you know
ghost in the shell things like that
virtual on oh yeah guys action style
mech stuff more so than like World of
Tanks and yeah definitely very speedy
you're doing a lot of sort of a lot of
jumping a lot of like getting on top of
buildings a little bit of boost action I
this is a competitive multiplayer match
that you're in right now exactly yes so
it's a five-on-five action RPG we're
going for kind of a league of legends
fort which player so there's an RPG
element of like building your tank
customizing it for your play style
working as a team and kind of that
dynamic we're we're aiming for and is
that you know that sort of that building
in League of Legends happens all during
the match mostly you know as you as you
gain kills getting gold your your your
specking you're buying items and you're
buying kit is that how you're doing it
here and jump tanks yeah so in jump
tanks it's more pre-match you build out
a battalion of Tanks I'm gonna have
three tanks per match and you can
customize the legs the shield the
chassis the gun and a bunch of
attachments like cloaking devices these
things that are like launch pads that
you can toss out and pop you up into
there so you can wash people which is
super fun oh you see that's like an
actual attack you can't come down on
someone and crush them so yeah so
there's lots of customization
and that's how you can kind of express
yourself in the game and the game mode
that's we're trying to make the game
mode have a bit of a meta like you're
talking about so the mode we're playing
today is called hunter and in Hunter one
player is the hunter on your team
they're kind of your main point score
which is that character right up here
with ya be on the big sort of ran around
so I want to protect them because o
matches over each kill they get they
keep getting a bounty higher and higher
and higher so the longer they stay alive
the more points they can earn for us um
but if they get killed someone else on
the team gets to play that role and so
it come becomes this kind of thing like
let's go get there hunter let's protect
our hunter and we also spawn health
pickups when the hunters killed so it's
like okay our hunters week let's go
protect that let's get them over there
and like Elam back up so we can keep
getting points so a very team focused
game yeah that's that's the goal is to
get people that talk to each other you
know as a dev team we're always not
playing with skype on and it's fun to be
like i'm trying to protect you yes i
hear ya i'm totally all very polite i'm
sure and complains anything yeah I is
this a look at your battalion here yes
so here's the three tanks you can see
all their stats and easily compare them
since there are a lot of numbers and
things to keep track of their regular
numbers there yet but I mean that's that
sort of par for the course for the game
when you have this kind of level of
customization you need you know you need
to know what stats they affect and how
the sort of overall profile off your
your tank is coming together exactly so
yeah we also want to make it really easy
to compare this stuff so it's like oh I
want this these legs oh here's these
stats we're gonna color code the numbers
so if it's red it's worse blue you know
it's going to universal language I
comparison don't do that yet so annoying
that's like listen guys we've got this
figure it out there's a way to do it
exactly yeah you're like why don't they
have this in this game don't understand
yeah so yeah as I said there's a lot of
different parts we're gonna have about
150 for the first series 150 parts 50
parts like 30 pilots 30 legs and these
are the pilots here's the pilot so
the pilots have an ally and a rival
ability in a passive so let's say we're
on the same team in you're my Ally when
you're fighting alongside me I have a
ring around me and if you're inside that
ring you're going to get a buff I'm
getting a buff yeah so it's like faster
energy regen or shield armor like region
or resistance so we want to like just
have a subtle way of being like play
with your team and you're going to do
better and in for the personality to
come through so it's like no seriously i
play with your team yeah yeah so for
competitive play like if you're playing
as a clan teams that are like conscious
of that and building battalions that
work well together are going to
definitely do better so let's see let's
see if I can help out my buddy we're the
blue team I'm the hunter so I better not
get killed but they're not playing doing
an interview so I have no problem for
you to just do the interview and then
you know exactly play to the best of
your ability yes such is the challenge
as we said before you are the challenges
we said before you I so is there if you
know you've got the character pictures
on the screen yeah and I almost I
picture them sort of whipping to each
other saying things do they talk at all
they have any voice acting here is it
mostly just to help you keep track of
who's on your squad and maybe what a
visual indicator of what kind of a
liabilities they're going to bestow upon
you yeah it would be great as a polished
thing to give them some more personality
you know a little banter you know like
in Street Fighter when they kind of like
you know talk a little trash after
imagine things like that it really it
really it's not plans we'd love to do it
kind of just focusing on the the
gameplay and all that but yeah bo would
be awesome well you certainly got some
character portraits uh go in there to
seem to lend themselves to some
character thanks i use the word
character a few more times to be really
in character for me
so it looks like you're you have
basically got a shot gun strapped to the
front of here too yeah so this is a
spread shot one of the 30 guns we hope
to have and yeah it's pars out tons of
tons of bullets we've got different
damage types so if I can shoot this
person you'll notice that the day which
numbers come up in a different color I
feel like that person is trying to help
you out here and you're down yeah
they're kind of like throwing the game
for me I'll fit but yeah so unimportant
you know what you want to show this show
off you know different parts of the game
in exactly I want to see you stomp oh
just missed the stop she keep block the
shot put their shield you'll notice that
you have a shield on the front of your
tank fire it raises up and exposes your
tank and i'll show you sort of have a
shield State Fire state yeah it's a
risk/reward thing and some of the
shields will block like 180 degrees so
you know if you're trying to regen your
energy you can just back up a name Adam
and block some shots and his energy is
the ammunition basically yeah the purple
bar up there dashing jumping double
jumping all that runs on energy so kind
of like Dark Souls stamina system uh-huh
you gotta you know filled your tank and
you know I need a ton of energy for this
gun so I'm gonna build a tank like that
yeah and manage that know when you're
gonna be low when you're gonna be you
know when you can press the advantage
etc exactly yeah so let's see we're also
going to have charged shots so you'll be
able to hold down the button release and
do like a different type of attack now
this is hunter mode with you know your
you as a hunter do bonus dent or get get
bounties that increase yeah I what other
kind of competitive modes are you guys
hoping to having jump tanks here we'll
probably have about two game modes we
don't want to split up the playerbase
too much similar to how like we you know
it's kind of a focus yeah yeah so we
want to we want to go for a really
strong game mode with the meta that
people can just get into and play again
and again and have fun we're destroying
that Park yeah yeah that was horrified
cherry blossom trees so another thing I
haven't mentioned yet is dynamic arenas
so
times when you play it'll be night
sometimes they'll be like a giant crane
there we're also going to have enemy
turrets and things like that that are
like creeps that are going to be like
attacking everybody so just different
elements like a drawbridge that might be
there for a short cut and next time you
play it's not there so you know with
multiplayer games you play hopefully
hundreds of matches and you know we just
want to make sure each time you play
there's something different that you can
take advantage you've got something
something fresh with some different
strategic considerations that very match
to match exactly which i think is
important when you're playing on same
map you're the same you know you maps
you guys are thinking of like rope
that's about six about six yeah six for
the first launch and then maps will
always be free for people who have the
game so maps will always be free and I
was just uh it connects going to be free
too dangerous no this uh we're looking
at like a model like magic the gathering
so you get like a starter pack for a
pretty horrible price okay dollars or
less uh-huh and you get a you know
handful of tanks and parts and then if
you want more content some booster packs
to get more parts at an affordable price
and so we just want to make it
accessible for people like that they
love it they want more variety they can
get some more parts I gotta tell you k
see the way that sort of these tanks are
jointed and the way the parts are put
together reminding me of connects those
like building toys yeah I used to play
with back in the day nice yeah it's not
like having a real flash back to that
although these are way more interesting
than the abominations i would put
together so is this I noticed that now
you have this sort of is that you're
you're using a shield that protects the
180 yeah so let's see if I could block
some of this person shots CEO not so six
able not real effect yeah I got about
two shots blocked and then I blew up so
and so you automatically then respawn as
the next tank in your battalion yeah
exactly so right below in the hut you
can see the order so in this one I got
132 so each time I die I cycle through
my tanks and so it's kind of like a deck
in a trading card game you don't know
what card you're going to get
so you know you're kind of like in a
different sync with your plate like two
other teammates and stuff so another
kind of cool thing is like we've got
inspiration from bullet hell and
Japanese shooters so like our networking
code you can get tons of bullets on
screen so that was one of the goals is
like we want to make a game where you
can dodge bullets that weave through
them not just like instant raycast
weapons like a lot of shooters yeah I
mean that you're you're spread gun was
moving pretty quick but you know I
imagine peps and heavier shot some you
know different weapon types you'd be
able to actually like this that looks
like it'd be pretty tough to dodge on my
cell unless you just leap frog away and
then yeah this one is a pretty mean from
close in range but I can't aim it up so
I kind of need to get on their their
level so just like pros and cons to
different weapons like this one the V
laser blades they kind of scissor
together a hug when they come you know
they swipe and then focus so it does
double damage if you can like get a line
I don't know ya know it's you can keep
your beam on them and they're shooting a
rail gun at me it looks like a top deck
okay so how did we do I'm an oblivious
play on gid round shooting yet better
than all the other red team players
there we go gamespot rules well your
score was better you got 14 more nice
gamespot does indeed rule ok see ya we
are not immune to flattery yeah there
you go nice ah very cool man so let's
take one more look at the battalion
alright let's switch up the gun here
let's throw in a shotgun real quick and
laser blades and how about a railgun and
there's sort of an aesthetic through
line between these tanks you know
there's that you got the sort of neon
highlights these jointed legs yeah is
but I'm sorry the Gradle yeah what is
that this thing is a at the top so this
one when you do crushing attacks it's
going to be tuned to do more damage I
said break a charge that way yeah so
yeah this one's funny so ok we just want
to do some wild ones with it different
silhouettes and like you know different
sort of attack so like let's see if I
can quickly get to a shield we've got a
shield with like a giant buzzsaw on the
front which is going to do more RAM
damage so if you boost into somebody oh
there we go so yeah looks like one of
those giant mining exactly yeah it's
totally safe right so yeah just it's a
fun or Katie game it's so this is almost
like a melee class they hit it out right
exactly so if you equip this one you
might be dashing into players trying to
knock them off of things or just grind
them um so yeah Oh someone shows all the
same kick that's okay yeah not all right
a little creepy some clones but uh you
know just like Street Fighter it's okay
if you want to pick the same characters
or anything goes in the world of jump
tanks I like your character who was like
triumphantly holding a briefcase above
his head yeah he's kind of the Japanese
salaryman guy he's got a tie tied around
his head yeah so yeah we have 30
original characters they're all crazy so
yeah as you see there's little legs that
come out of the kind of a drill thing
that I'm driving around help so you can
also choose patterns so we'll have like
camo in different kind of patterns you
can put on your parts and yeah you
really yeah seems like customization
obviously a big part of why he just got
crushed Josh lead programmer they're
just coming in for the kill he's deadly
good oftentimes I cannot beat him so
we'll see if he a pretty quick kill was
that are there some are there any
weapons at do sort of that one hit Hill
or like a to hit yeah right now the jump
crush is tuned pretty high we're going
to tune it down a little bit so it's
more balanced but it all just seems like
that's to get mar 22 lands cuz you're
these tanks move around pretty quick
yeah it's definitely a skill shot like
look at that you're flying down like
let's see if I can do ha yeah it's I
believe in your case a thanks oh I'm
gonna keep on trying I'll get one of
these guys is you can dump oh there we
go thousand seventeen damage yeah so
it's a then you're looking at other
shots is like 20 David shell yeah a
little bit over you right now you're not
coming back from a jump crush uh hiding
under the brain I was smart not a bad
move yeah here we go yeah so our teams
off to an ok start eight points well
look at very cool a very fast-paced uh
you know and sort of as the demo are
here it's a little bit tricky for you to
coordinate team tactics you're not on
that but that is something you guys are
hoping to encourage exactly yeah I yeah
that's a big goal for us is having
people communicate we want to put in
some hot keys so you can hit a button
it'll be like come over here and flash
on the radar things like that so kind of
make ways square if you don't have chat
you can do it maybe with some like other
method like a quick little press ya know
that there is so yeah we're coming to
steam steam so we've been accepted to
steam and I can't announce a date yet
but are you guys know so is that going
to be steam early access or are you guys
just going to go full release right onto
steam we're not that brave no just uh
yeah we'd love to do early access get
player feedback and just you know start
building the comedy and like start
taking you put from people on what they
like about the game and what they
all that sort of stuff I mean that's so
cool coming from concept development you
can never like interface with your
community during the development process
yeah yeah so that's the great thing
about indie dev it's like if we want to
talk to players we can so that's what we
want to do right on well Casey I wish
you guys the best of luck developing a
pudding out out of there on the steam
and looking ahead to the release of jump
tanks which is at some nebulous point in
the future yeah hopefully in the next
six plus months alrighty access very
cool man thank you so much for coming on
to you yeah here's the game spot all
right folks we're gonna change things up
now on this stage a little bit for a
little while now we've been running a
tournament in NBA 2k14 and the finals
are at hand we've got a giant novelty
check over here five thousand dollars
are at stake we've got Homer rabar I
coming up here to call the final match
that is going to be coming up shortly
we're gonna get set up don't go away
because it's gonna be a nail butter all
right problem thing I'm Chris waters
thank you for sticking with us during
the demos and homers coming up here to
blow you guys away with some NBA 2k14
finals stick around